[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
and welcome back to the leia higher pen
show powered by icon
plus so a quick news announcement for
you as always
icon is kicking off 2021 with the launch
of d5 projects
omm finance um balanced dao
icon phi and its new governance system
cps
all developed to financially support
contributions to the ecosystem so
always some great news coming up icon
there um i want to say thank you to my
sponsors blockbuy i use them to earn up
to 8.6
interest on my uscc i think that's
insane um i don't think that kind of
resonates when i say it that's 8.6
interest especially when we're seeing
negative interest rates across europe
i think we saw 0.01 from the bank of
england so that's
pretty crazy and then you can also get i
think it's 250
depending on how much you um deposit
with them so i've left the link
everywhere should be in the bio the
comments wherever it should be
um and a final shout out to coinflip so
they are doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass
adoption
they now have 1 200 bitcoin atms
so giving everyday people access to
bitcoin i have a discount code if you
want you can get 10
um off your transactions so i'll leave
that somewhere in the comments
so today we have a really cool guest um
somebody who i really admire somebody
who i've become quite friendly with
recently
thinks she's brilliant and i just want
to learn more about her so
let's welcome bitcoin liz how are you
doing
hey i'm doing good thanks for having me
on and thanks for the kind words
i've been following you as well and i've
seen your guests on the show so i feel
like super super oral that you chose to
to get me on the show
it's it's great to be here yeah it's
great to have you because i feel like
we've just met this year we've both sort
of just like
popped up out of nowhere um well i guess
sort of seems that way for everyone else
but you know we only just met this year
and i kind of want to know
a lot more about you who is bitcoin liz
what is bitcoin there's so before we
talk crypto
i want to know how would you sort of
define yourself
tell us something about who you are okay
yeah define i think this is always a
tricky question but i i guess
a part of uh what defines who i am you
support my
my background so i'm born and raised in
sweden to estonian parents
and i grew up with two native language
at home quite modest home
and yeah my parents were immigrants so
they they kind of had to build up a new
life here they were really young when
they moved here
and um i guess the estonian mindset has
been
with me for ever since in the beginning
i've never really
could place myself in one place i'm not
either swedish or estonian it's kind of
having the boat
which i think is cool uh and uh yeah
we're talking about the estonian mindset
i think we're all yeah what is that
yeah because um estonia got independent
from the ussr we started uni
in 1991 and you know we built up the
country from scratch basically and
everyone
in estonia would say are you know we
don't don't take anything from granted
we know that we need to work hard to
become successful and to make a living
and
i think that is something that has been
with me ever since beginning and really
defined who i am because sweden was a
welfare state long long before estonia
got independent and
i don't think the same mindset exists in
in the young people
in twitter in general today so yeah
we we grew up here in stockholm in the
suburbs and
uh um i went to estonia school here in
sweden and uh
it's really been a part um of everything
and another thing uh fun fact i guess
show is also
the estonian way thank you i got my
first uh robert kiyosaki book which that
poor dad from from my dad
when i was 11 years old and he was like
read this you need to know this you need
to understand this
because then you will become rich in the
future and you know how to
make passive income i didn't even know
what passive income was then
and how to protect your wealth from
sharks and all that
uh of course i didn't understand
everything in the book by then but it
kind of like saw a seed in me or
from early on which has been with me for
yeah ever since
since then but yeah to to just define
myself i would say
i'm a kind person i i'm really curious
important
that i have around me i show a lot of
caring and take
take care everyone around me i'm really
active
i'm almost like restless i need to have
something to do all the time i love to
have many
things ongoing all the time and that's
that's when i perform the best that's
when i
feel the best i'm also curious every
every time i visit a new country i want
to know about the culture the history
i'm not the one who goes to like history
museums or like that i'm out in the
streets exploring
i want to know uh everything about the
place i'm visiting
and uh yeah learn as much as possible
about the place yeah and i think
answered
i think you answered that like that the
best way i've ever heard somebody ask a
description about themselves yeah you
went into detail so
i think that's really interesting we
said about the estonian mindset um
i think i i've spent some time in
eastern europe and i really
like that i really like there is a
mindset it's kind of like a hard work
it's quite unemotional isn't it as well
given like the history like you said
um and it's kind of just like no matter
how cold it gets no matter how hard it
gets we push through you know
i i quite like that but you're based in
sweden so this is insane
um because you are literally one of i
know there's probably three other
countries
on this planet but you are the pop you
are living in a country
that has not had a lockdown this is
insane
so we need to get into this because i've
so i'm based in the uk
it is horrendous here um you know
christmas was cancelled thank you boris
johnson um
our what else was canceled new year's
eve is cancelled everything is cancelled
gyms are shocked it's quite unbelievable
i then fled and went to romania where
it's equally as nuts there
nearly got fined for wearing a mask
outside for not wearing a mask outside
sorry
um but you're living your best life off
in sweden where there's no lockdown tell
us how's it been
yeah well it's hard to imagine how it
would be with a lock that have to say so
i'm extremely grateful that we have had
quite a normal life
uh the worst thing here was when the
gyms were closed for two weeks
i couldn't go there but other than that
yeah it's it's been very
very normal but again it's hard to know
if it's
the right way or not because i in the
summer for example i don't know what
happens to swedish people but but with
summer comes everyone starts partying
you know hanging out which which is like
normal of course
yeah but i do also believe that that may
may cause
the virus to spread more to elderly we
didn't take as much
care of elderly people that i i believe
we would have uh or should have done
uh but of course again i'm super super
happy for it for the freedom and
actually like
that the government puts it in our hands
it's our choice like
what we do and take responsibility uh
together and not that the government
takes the decision for us
so in that place way i'm really happy
the way it is
because i cannot imagine how it like
tough it must be with a with a lockdown
especially
like mentioning that i'm restless i need
to have something to do all the time
um so yeah it's been
well relatively normal but like what's
the mentality though because like the
mentality here for example and actually
globally
is very much we should you know lock
down even harder
um you know we should wear masks all the
time
um it's it's really intense so
do swedish people not sort of share that
mentality
are people not putting pressure on your
government particularly journalists are
they not putting pressure on your
government at all
yeah now now they are putting more
pressure because
well it looks like we are not doing that
well comparing to neighbor countries
however one thing that i see like in
general
among the general public is that we are
very aware of mental health issues and
we believe that we will stop
a lot of this happening in the future so
that is something that we always lean
back on that
no matter what we at least stop this we
made sure that people
can hang out with each other and not put
ourselves yeah in
mental health issues which is yeah it's
widely spoken about in sweden it's not a
taboo
uh topic to discuss and i believe it is
like that
it's having a long time not being able
to socialize it
it affects you a lot and so there we
are all i think agreeing here that we
are doing the right thing but then of
course
the end result it's difficult to say i
would say that now people are maybe
putting more pressure on the government
and now the government is well telling
you that we're doing this together
we have a common responsibility to make
the best out of the situation
do you think you're locked down do you
think sweden will will sort of fall to
the global pressure and
lock down sorry if they
like did you think do you think that's
full to like the global pressure
and eventually lock down in 2021 or do
you think they would have done it by now
i think they would have done it by now
and it's like too late to back down i
think
it's it would be weird to do it now uh
so i i don't believe in it now we got
straight
more like strict restrictions during
christmas and europe that we are not
allowed to be more than eight people in
in the same room and like that but it's
just recommendations you know it's not
that you you will get fined or
anything for it and so still we have the
the choice to make um and yeah i respect
that
i really do i respect that i respect
the fact that you have the choice you
know i i respect the recommendation and
then i respect the freedom to do as you
wish for the recommendation
um but let's let's chat about crypto i
want to know
how did you get in to crypto was it
through ivan
or was it after him or did you get him
in like what happened yeah so um
shortly i got in like a couple of months
before i met ivan
but i didn't know that much about it so
long story short
i i was um while i was studying business
administration at university
and i was taking well business
administration is like really broad
program you have finance marketing
organization and all that
but in my finance class uh we talked a
lot about how
uh well the stock markets work and we
were
touching a little bit upon that there
are uh i think like digital currencies
and then i remember a couple of guys in
my class they were bragging
how they made tons of money on bitcoin
and i was like okay
did that caught my attention so i
started to
you know google more about it what is
this and um
i don't know for me right away i was
like okay this this is how future money
would look like when i read about it
and um that's when i invested like or
put money in in bitcoin the first time
but i didn't
honestly i didn't do that much research
before i i
made my first investment but again
yeah so this was in november 2017 uh my
first but it wasn't a lot of money that
i missed i mean i was a student
and i didn't have that much savings or
anything but i
i was already a little bit invested in
stocks and this was just a natural
thing to to money as well um but
so so that then i kind of follow it a
little bit but i i was definitely not
following any influencers on youtube or
anything
about it just a little bit maybe and
then i met ivan in
april 2018 it was
through my thesis partner i was writing
my thesis then and um
she knew i when she was following her
him on on youtube
and she was just like we saw him in a
co-working space because we were
working there or studying there and she
went to talk to him and i was like okay
i'm gonna go say hi to this guy i don't
know who
is and then we spoke a little bit about
crypto and he told that he's involved in
that and
um yeah i think we asked like okay where
do you see crypto going and i
said my opinion that i believe that for
mass adoption we need uh
you know facebook come up with their own
currency or something like that
which which happened as well they did
yeah yeah we can talk about that and um
yeah so i would say that i was involved
before but ivan really got me involved
when i met him because yeah he got me
in on crypto conferences and i started
to see that there
actually this is a real industry and
people are building so many cool
projects and
uh yeah so that this was during the ico
bubble uh basically when
me and i went and started to go to
crypto conferences um
yeah so uh yeah yeah it was actually
yeah super cool uh so i would definitely
not be
that heavily into crypto as i am now
without ivan no way
that's cute i like it so let's talk
about bitcoin for a second then
so you put a little bit in back in
november 2017
not enough to sort of be sort of living
on a beach and be done with with
everyone
but talk to me about bitcoin because i
know you're super bullish on bitcoin
it's bitcoin liz it's not all coinless
um
yeah so oh list bitcoin so tell me
what is it about bitcoin that just
really
makes you think yes this is the future
why bitcoin why not
a different currency so i think
when i first read about it the thing
that grabbed me really was that it's
you know there's no central authority
third party involved
um between there so it's maybe one of
the big most basic things
uh about it because i was at that time i
was angry with the banks because i
remember i opened my first savings
accounts
and at in the beginning i earned
interest on the money i i stored that
but then in sweden we got negative
interest rates and i had to pay
them for for storing my money so already
there was i was unbelievable
yes it's unbelievable i was like i'm
having my money
in the bank i'm paying them but they can
use that money to
you know even earn even more interest so
already there i was angry with the bank
so how long were negative interest rates
going on across europe because i know
that they were going on i mentioned at
the beginning of the show but
we've not really seen that in the uk and
i think the bank of england have ruled
it out
but how long have you guys have negative
interest rates and what are people doing
to circumvent that
so we have had it since well ever since
i got my first bank account basically
one year after so i think it's like
eight years it has to be and and people
don't really
think about it as an issue anymore it's
it's normal now
people i mean i i understand why
you would do it to stimulate the economy
people to spend
but it's been easy look at that as
blackmail though but okay yeah
like i always see that as blackmail
because it's kind of like
it's kind of like you have to spend your
money otherwise
we'll spend it it's like
i think it's insane um but i want to
look at 2020 because 2020 has been
the most crazy year um so what would you
say some of the most
interesting and the most significant
things are that have happened
in crypto this year yeah so a lot has
happened yeah and i guess we need to
start with the bitcoin harmony
and that caught a lot of i would say
mainstream attention i remember
remember when it's uh in the spring i
was still working at my
old job which is uh like traditional
company not sex savvy people and they
were like
oh i heard about this bitcoin hobbing
thing and i was like oh
how uh so of course it gave bitcoin a
lot of attention
and then yeah um and it was an important
event um
especially for for a bit from price now
i guess and
that's priced in there just gonna jump
in do you think it's priced in like do
you think
that's what we're seeing now as a result
of the halving i don't know it's so hard
to say i
i honestly i think
no i don't think it's completely priced
i don't know i don't yeah it's difficult
to say
i yeah i'll i'll leave with that i i
don't think it's completely uh no
uh priced in but of course you remember
the excitement before the hallway after
halloween so that was definitely um
something i remember um and um
then of course the d5 summer and with
all the projects
and also i mean that was really when we
saw true innovation
uh because i i believe that nifa is uh
challenging traditional financial
services
it's possible that there are real
projects and um
and of course just the institutional
money that has uh run into
bitcoin it's crazy now we are really put
on the map
i mean micro strategy we have yeah
people
took us and i mean people see
yeah square everything so we have like
really
significant people speaking up for us
and that makes yeah we can't be ignored
anymore
due to that it's really really important
and that part
um yeah yeah i mean i think you know i
would definitely say that 2020
has to be actually i would i would go as
far to say as
it's been the most powerful year for the
industry um
for so many different reasons um okay
you can look at d5 it's like your sort
of like initial example because
that inherently just challenges the
traditional system right i think
it puts people in the financial map
people can borrow money
do what they need um you know money that
they obviously
previously never have access to um but
you know the halving was insane i mean
that was just like an incredible it's
always an amazing marketing
opportunity for bitcoin um you know the
printing of money that we that we've
seen
i always found like that just kind of
was insane because
i'm always obviously trying to get more
people into crypto i'm trying to sort of
like explain to them why bitcoin is
going to be surnamed is going to be so
um revolutionary
um and it's so hard sometimes to sort of
explain that to them especially when we
talk about countries like venezuela
which see like hyperinflation and we
don't really see that kind of inflation
in the west but then
you can sort of give them this this sort
of case study of 2020 and just sort of
be like look how much money is being
printed like you know
um choose something which is a
deflationary asset something which has
you know
um deflationary sort of strategies built
in the harbinger stuff i just think
it it's been amazing and then you know
because you and i were chatting
yesterday and we were also talking about
um how important things that people like
paypal
are and microstrategy and all this stuff
because i just think that you know
people like jack dorsey people like
michael saylor they don't put
millions into or billions i can't
remember how much it was at this point
but
they don't put that much money in um
to sort of sell at like even 10 grand
higher i don't believe it
i don't believe that they're not and
there was also um
that rapper what was his name it begins
with l
is it is it lock lock oh gosh i'm really
not good i'm not it's not it's not my
thing that but
what was his name if anyone remembers
his name write it in the comments it was
lock or lock oh i don't know but he he
put a lot in and
so many different celebrities as well
who put a lot in this year and i think
that's also just like another
um incredible i guess sort of marketing
opportunity for bitcoin
um but in terms of the pandemic
how do you think that has affected
bitcoin so
in general i think it has had a good
effect um
because it kind of made people rethink
about how
i believe at least like how the monetary
system works just with the stimulus
in the u.s uh you kind of think that
okay
how does it actually work that you can
just bring
endless amount of money and devalue your
own
uh you know developing the currency uh i
would be frustrated if i would be in the
us
and see that kind of stimulus being
printed and but again also people got
the stimulus checks and they had more
money to invest so they started to look
okay what should i do with my money
but even that got me but even that got
me like because i
okay so it's no secret that i ten that
i'm
that i don't fall on like the left of
like the political and economic and like
fiscal
system i think that's no no secret if
you follow me so like when people when
the government are handing out money and
then people put it into bitcoin
i'm in like two minds about that yeah so
i'm just like
i'm like that's great that you put it
into bitcoin that's cool but like don't
you need the money
isn't that why the government gave it
yeah like you need it to buy like
groceries and stuff i don't know
yeah yeah no i i i agree
but your friends are and your family
okay so
when you talk about what you do when you
talk about bitcoin number one how into
it
are they do they think you're crazy if
you manage to
um convince anybody to buy any bitcoin
um and how do you describe it to them
like what do you say and
you know you're sitting around the
dinner table or whatever and you're so
just like oh my god bitcoin reached new
highs like what do they think
yes it's very mixed feelings i i think
my older like grandmothers and
grandfathers they and they have a
difficult time to understand it but
they're kind of like okay i know you you
are smart so yeah
i i trust that you're doing the right
thing um
but my one of my grandma yeah my grandma
she really understands because
one of the advantages of living in
estonia is that it's super digitalized
i mean you can't do anything by going to
a physical place
everything is online so even my grandma
she she understands that everything is
online and
yeah that's where it is and that's how
the future is going to look like so it
makes
it easier for them to understand that
money is going to be digital as well
and even estonia was one of the first
countries to start looking at the
like own digital currency i think they
even they planned it
yeah in the beginning with vitalik even
but then yeah
then eve took off and everything so it
was put on a hold
uh so i think for for them it's still
quite natural but
they have a hard time to understand like
okay but so
what what actually gives it value what's
the value of position and
and that part um but so usually when i
explain i just explained that
so we own you know the network
there's no one who can tamper with it
and and it's secure it's backed by
blockchain technology all that and um
yeah so i i i don't get they don't think
i'm crazy
they just think it's okay it's super
cool that she has something that she is
interested in
and uh yeah and i remember when i was
working at my previous
job as i mentioned which was a
traditional corporation
people were actually quite interested
they were like okay she knows something
that can be
used used in the future so i i instantly
got interesting to people because of
that they asked me quite a lot and i
remember even
one of my closest colleagues and who i
worked with closely she
she eventually invested in bitcoin
because her brother was more as well but
we talked about it like all the time
and she understand that you know people
have the
the pre-assumptions that it's for
criminals and it's only criminals
involved there
but when they see that okay i'm in there
and i'm actually like doing a lot of
research
exactly so so then it created a lot more
trust for them as well and
yeah i managed to get at least one email
uh
in bitcoin yeah i think that's so funny
we said um about your grandma there
because
my grandpa he lives in the north of
england so i went up to see him just
before the pandemic had kicked in just
to help stock his fridge and all that
bless him
um and he literally thinks i work in
something really criminal i'm not being
funny he turned around to me
and said does your father know what you
do
i was like what do you mean like he he
literally
he can't he he he can't even understand
facebook bless him he
um he sort of thinks like so he he was
looking for like
a grocery store nearby or something and
you can sort of go on groups on facebook
and ask
um so my mom has said you know go on
facebook and ask and my grandpa was like
oh do we call facebook
you know like yellow pages yeah
so there's kind of no yeah there's kind
of no hope lesson but you know my
my mom is bitcoin crazy yeah
she's crazy like every day
so she i've got her on block five and
every day she's like she's like yeah
like
let's look at my portfolio and i'm like
mom i was like you need to chill
like you just need to calm down and
she's like tell me when to sell time we
went to sound i'm like no
we don't smell okay we don't sell we
hold
um and then my brother as well he
he didn't buy i told him to buy a 10. i
told him about earlier
but we were having a serious discussion
at 10 because my mom had got in at 10k
um and a bit earlier but she got in
property at 10k and i told my brother to
get in
and um he was just like no i'll buy
below and i'm like i don't think it's
going below
you know how long it spent at 8k how
long it spent at 9k
and then it did go above 10k then it
went down again there was that point
when we sort of knew
that nobody made the joke anymore nobody
was like we're not going to see it
everybody knew we weren't seeing below
10k again um
so he didn't buy and now he's like
thinking to buy at 26 and i'm like
oh my god yeah but at least you got i
mean that's really cool together and
so it's so fun to hear that your mom is
like all in
it's nice but she's too much literally
she absolutely stresses me out
constantly
she's like like oh i get a message again
i don't get good morning my dear loving
daughter i get
28.1 oh i'm like mom
you need to stop but you're also um
really big on ethereum so i kind of want
to understand what it is about ethereum
and why do you like it um there are a
lot of concerns sorry there are a lot of
concerns that it's
um a lot of ether were pre-mined
um and that it's it's not as
decentralized or whatever
or what are your thoughts in it there
and why you say bullish on it
so i think you can't really compare
ethereum to
bitcoin i think they these are different
uh purposes so so bitcoin is
a great store value i would say uh while
ethereum is
it provides something different um i
would say
now with d5 and all the rivets the
derivatives and everything that it is
providing i think
that that is huge for it um and
yeah i i really don't think you can
compare
to bitcoin in the same way um and um
just how big the community is and
how they are building and what it
enables
to for for the blockchain industry as a
whole i think
that is super important and as well now
especially
when we have a lot of attention on the
um ripple lawsuits
actually scc has said that ethereum is
is not a security
which kind of gives a you know it it
makes this room a
good choice because you know that the
sccf has at least
said that you know it's it's not a
security you won't have that issue
uh with the dream but other than that's
i don't know i just think you it
provides
a lot of value for for the crypto
community and uh yeah yeah especially
with the king of the old saying
yeah no but especially looking at the
derivatives market it's huge
it's it's really really big and yeah
that's
that's what comes with it yeah i think
um
so the ceo of old coinbase i always say
this i have to cite him um
he told me the best he sort of break it
down and
the clearest way to kind of understand
and he was like bitcoin is gold 2.0
ethereum is digital amazon and i was
like
oh okay i was like i can work at that i
like that that makes a lot of sense so
you know they're they're different and
they're not comparable
and you know bitcoin is in a league of
its own in its own way
and a theorem is in its illegal of its
own in its own way doing whatever it
does with smart contracts programmable
money and so on decentralized apps and
all that stuff
um i think it's pretty cool but what are
the projects have you got your eyes on
for 2021 any other alts
which you're interested in and you want
to share with us yeah so
i thought about that a lot i'm not that
into
alts i mean i follow a lot of projects
just to see
what is out there um recently what i got
my eyes on is is polka dots i think
the yeah what they're doing is great and
they have performed really well now
recently as well
so so that is definitely something that
i will keep an eye on in 2021 as well
because yeah it's a great ecosystem and
uh just
just the the interoperability they are
providing
um between yeah it's important for
and i think they're good doing great and
now i think they are like what are the
top
top six stop seven something yeah i
think or something like that yeah
definitely yeah something like top six
or something
um but i have an interesting question i
really want to talk to you about because
people must come to you all the time and
ask you you know can you talk about my
projects whether it be on youtube or
whether it be on twitter or wherever it
is
so there are almost so many new projects
you know we said like defy was um
huge in the summer it was like summer d5
so how do you spot a scam so what are
your best ways to work out whether
something's number one a scam
and number two whether something is just
a really crappy project and
you know you don't like the fundamentals
or you don't like the marketing behind
it or whatever it is you don't really
sort of believe in it so
how do you sort of spot that and then
decide whether or not to talk about it
um so yeah we can start with the the
scan part
i think it has become much more
difficult to to spot a scam because
they're getting better and better
um but i think what you need to look
like at is
what they are offering um if they are
offering like guaranteed
um yeah returns on investment it's
probably not true
because yeah you can't guarantee things
like that and we have seen
many projects that are guaranteeing like
okay at least this percentage of
return on investment uh no it doesn't
exist in the real world
so yeah if it does seem too too good to
be true
it probably is and um yeah i think
also looking at the team if they have a
if they're open with
the team working with them it's also a
good sign
i know many projects in crypto also they
want to be anonymous and
and all that but i believe if it's for
me at least it's important to know
that real people and who they are
working behind the team
and the project and then of course
i mean looking i think what makes this
scam
successful is of course the human
psychology because we do believe that it
might be
something really good that's how bit
connect
and onecoin got so big and i'm talking
about onecoin it
they they their strategy was to you know
target people who had no clue about
crypto
and the crazy thing is that i even had
an old lady at my previous job
she had invested in one claim yes
yes what did they say no
she was contacted by like her some
relative
and said like okay you will get you'll
get return on investment
you just need to put this in and you
know and she said like
but i don't really know what it was i
just said that i would get more money
for this and i'm like
you know it's so sad to see and that it
works
um and i even had one relative uh who
had invested in one coin so one coin
was like really really crazy but that
would really show how naive people are
and um yeah they are really believing
which is sad which is sad
um but again i think i'm hoping that as
big
of a scam as one coin was and bit
connect we won't see again
um because i will we have become smarter
but again um if they are really
promising like guaranteed returns it's
probably
that's a big warning sign and but other
than that the
answering what projects i would work on
and not
i think as long as yeah i'm looking at
the use case
if i see that this maybe it's not the
best product
but if it can bring more adoption it can
be simple
i don't know uh merch bitcoin merch
i mean somehow people still love it i am
mean to that because i
i love clothes i i like i'm not going to
show those things and i think it's also
a way to
spread awareness about crypto um
and yeah i mean at least you have a
product right i think i think that's
kind of like the thing which i've kind
of landed on
um through this whole d5 thing is like
do they have a product
because there's so much conversation and
there's so much talk and there's so much
like technical language
um which really kind of like coats
an absence of anything in the middle
right like what is their product there's
no product there's no use case they
don't do anything
and then i'm you know people are just
buying into something
and that is something which is like
become such an issue for me
um you know i have uh it doesn't matter
who i i saw a company
a company came and sort of said will you
work with us um and
i was just reading through their white
paper and their website
and i'm just there like this is just a
lot of language where's your product
and i didn't see the product and i sent
it to some send it to the people at all
coinbase as well because i think they're
great and they read it through and
they're like leia no that's not a good
one and i was like i didn't think it was
you know
there's no product um another thing i'll
say as well
um in terms of sort of like a new people
getting into the space um which i
obviously want to ask you about um i
totally agree with you when it comes to
anonymous um anonymous character so like
of course i'm absolutely pro anonymity
pro privacy each to their own do what
you want freedom liberation
you get you get the point um but as an
individual
on this side somebody who's potentially
an investor or a trade or whatever
i and you guys like asked me to sort of
think
okay how much do i want to invest
in a project which has an anonymous
founder simply because they can't be
held accountable
for their actions so there's nothing
necessarily inherently wrong with
anonymity
it's just they can't be held accountable
and i think
that's what people need to consider you
know what would you say some of the main
things are people should consider before
getting in so yeah it depends on
on what is important for you for for me
example as i mentioned i would like to
see the people behind it because that
that is a way that
that's the thing that is important to me
just because that's the way i decide
uh if i believe it on and or not
um but of course then again i think
you need to think what are the like the
um
what are the things that are going to
matter in the future like you have to
think about
is this going to be an important thing
in a couple of years and a couple of
months
and to really see the potential in it
and if you don't understand
what what their vision and what the goal
is of the project
then probably it's not a good thing to
invest in because i think it's important
that you understand
the product or the service that they are
they have and
some can be super complicated as you
said they're not even having a product
so i think it's important that you
understand it because that makes you
better at evaluating if it's a good
product or not and
there's a lot of people just writing a
lot of words as you said
without having a true meaning and it
just sounds good but
it's not really clear what what they're
actually
providing i wondered if you
had any thoughts um on ripple the sec
you know have you been following it at
all i have been following
a little bit but honestly not not i mean
that much
i think i think it
will have a huge impact on on us of
course
but again um i wasn't that into ripple
before i
didn't think there were a great project
or anything like that
i didn't have anything invested in them
and but i think this shows as well that
the
sec is having an eye on us and that
there might be
coming more things like this and that's
also
why as i you know chat yesterday i'm
hoping for an etf i think
the sec needs to um just because we have
so much institutional money it's we're
not talking about
just you know us the crypto community
having their money now
now it's actually billions of
institutions who have the money
they have a responsibility to make sure
that it is a secure
and regulated in a good way uh market
that's their responsibility
so i think they won't get away with it
and we might see more cases like this
come up of course yeah i think it's kind
of strange
the whole thing is just odd in my
opinion um
like it makes sense yes but i was been
talking to some people and doing some
research and i think
from what i've read and what i
understand i think brad garlinghouse
sort of sold i think more than half of
his xrp like over a year ago like this
time last year which is just
odd in my opinion you know like these
lawsuits or whatever like they don't
come out of nowhere i just find like the
timing kind of strange
um but what do we know um
what do you think um 2021 is gonna look
like then um
we spoke yesterday so we were trying a
bit about stable coins cbdc's
so nfts what is that going to look like
in 2021
so first of all i think more and more
people will get involved in crypto
and especially now institutions joining
and
yeah we are put on the map we had yeah
as we
mentioned microstrategy square fidelity
blackrock and we had even a new
institution today i think
joining so it's almost last one every
day maybe i think it was massive
it was the other week i think today was
something like green
that it was something yeah i'm not sure
but it
you know we see this almost every day so
it's not even that significant anymore
um but that's that means that more and
more people will
like okay what is this actually that
these institutions are putting them
running
and so i definitely think more um a
larger group
of people would be part of this
community and
um again i think bitcoin will uh will
lead
in 2021 and
yeah it will reach new all-time highs
for for sure i'm
i'm sure of that and nfts
might come back more and now we kind of
have cooled off there
if we really can find um use case for
them
that yeah i mean not even now the use
case is good
but i think um it takes a little bit
time to
to evolve it and put it in actually in
real life as well
as we added yesterday you can actually
use it in retail and to
for products to verify the authenticity
of it and then again i believe it will
be big in gaming
and collectibles in asia is
like specifically people love
collectibles there it can be
yeah whatever so um i believe nfts can
can come back
and um yeah we we don't know what what's
coming next
next there will definitely be something
completely new and
it will be exciting for sure that's all
we know um
but yeah i mean i i definitely agree
with you i think um
nfts i mean i i said this to you
yesterday i've said this to everybody
before i always say this i'm just a
broken record at this point but i i like
i
mean it wholeheartedly the whole world
is going digital like
dating is digital eating is digital
working is digital
everything is digital it's just
inevitable that
everything else will go digital and you
know we were talking about
um like designer handbags you know rolex
watches or whatever it is
of course you know verifying them um
verifying that authenticity will be
digital and
you know i think blockchain technology
will be a part of that um
like we were saying whether it says an
nft or not who knows
um but just finally what are
your final thoughts um
to just about crypto in general to the
crypto community just speak directly
to them from the heart you know okay
well i
first of all i love the crypto community
i'm so happy to be part of it
and i do believe that we are
early on very early on and we will get
rewarded for it
in the future uh so even though someday
it might feel like
am i doing the right thing i might you
know question yourself
is this a crazy industry actually like
is this all made up you know sometimes
i get at least those thoughts but i want
to say like yeah
it's normal that we get those thoughts
but just bear out i mean
we are this community is growing and
it's really really great there are real
projects being built and i do believe
that
we will see like more worldwide
adoption and we will um yeah we will
really get rewarded for it in the future
and i think when we think about
blockchain technology at this whole i
think it will be a part of many
businesses
it is today as well one of the things
with estonia if you can return back to
that estonia is using blockchain
in healthcare 90 of our
medical data is stored with the
blockchain technology
so i think we will see a lot more
solutions like that the businesses are
actually going to use it to protect data
and to verify products where they come
from
in supply chain and that would also of
course mean
that there will be more jobs
made in in blockchain industry will
create more more jobs and more people
will enter just because they see it as a
job opportunity career opportunity
as well and in general i think
we would we will mature really quickly
and it will be
just another industry that we have now
and each industry
probably in tech but it will be a
natural part of many businesses
because there are really really good use
cases for it and
it would be yeah stupid for businesses
not to
to take advantage of that and yeah and
as
uh as mentioned before i think we will
probably see more regulations as well
from
scc has to um take their responsibility
or their role
and make sure that it is a secured
market
yeah i'm absolutely with you i think
regulation is coming
um i don't know whether we'll like it or
not i don't know whether they'll start
from the beginning i imagine regulation
and
the likes of cbdc's will absolutely sort
of
be some kind of war with with the
community and like yeah
initial sort of like ethos and i guess
gold for the community
um but yeah we'll have to see how it
goes i think i can't remember what you
said but it sort of made me think of
the idea that like i feel you know
investors
and people like you and i um you know
we're sort of like at the end of the day
gambling not just our money but like our
careers on the on the success of
the success of bitcoin isn't it because
if bitcoin fails then like they say
yeah everything else fails but hey we
believe in it um
so where can people find you so you can
find me on
twitter uh liz bitcoin or bitcoin liz
and youtube as well uh same bitcoin is
and instagram if you want to that's more
private and
connected to to our puppy um but yeah
there is
lizette which is my full name
there you go liz thank you so much for
coming on guys thank you so much for
tuning in don't forget to tune in
next thursday it'll be back to normal
time so it will be 12 est which is five
gmt if you're in europe that's six e s
no et that's it too many time zones
alright guys thank you so much for
tuning in we'll see you next time bye
thank you bye